if i'm going somewhere and there's ducks i will stop what i'm doing to go and like interact with the ducks what like when we talk about transform reduce i'll be able to talk about how i met you oh is this is this a pg rated podcast no no no we're allowed to say whatever we want the most important thing and you gotta leave this part in the most important thing is that our podcast has to be better than jf and ch podcast. That'll be the opening. That'll be the opening clip. Have you have you listened to their podcast? No, I've not listened to their podcast. Welcome to episode zero of ADSP, the podcast recorded on November 14th, 2020. My name is Connor and with my co-host Bryce, today we're going to be talking about what our favorite algorithms are. Hey man, how's it going?
如果我要去某个地方而且那里有鸭子，我会停下正在做的事去跟鸭子互动。比如当我们谈论 transform reduce 时，我就可以讲讲我是怎么遇到你的。噢，这是个 PG 级（建议家长指导）的播客吗？不不，我们可以畅所欲言。最重要的一点——你得把这部分剪进去——最重要的一点是，我们的播客必须比 JF 和 CH 的播客更好。这就是开场白。这将是开场片段。你听过他们的播客吗？不，我没听过他们的播客。欢迎收听 ADSP 第零期节目，本播客录制于 2020 年 11 月 14 日。我是康纳（Connor），我的联合主持人是布莱斯（Bryce），今天我们要聊聊我们最喜欢哪些算法。嘿，兄弟，最近怎么样？
It's pretty good. I just woke up, had myself a bagel that I napped in my couch for half an hour. Was that intentional, mentioning bagels in the first 30 seconds of our first inaugural episode of this podcast? I mean mean it is a meme with me but uh but yeah but yeah so uh what's this podcast about it's gonna be about algorithms data structures and anything and everything we want to talk about so for those of you that that don't know uh this podcast is going to be modeled after one of my favorite podcasts called magic read-along which is just two guys, you know, hopping on what sounds like a phone call, chatting about some things programming related, some things not. And hopefully it's entertaining for those that are listening.
挺好的。我刚醒，吃了百吉饼，在沙发上小睡了半小时。在我们的首期开播节目头 30 秒里提到百吉饼，这是故意的吗？我的意思是，这对我来说是个梗，不过，是的，所以……这个播客是关于什么的？它将关于算法、数据结构，以及任何我们想聊的话题。所以对于那些还不知道的人来说，这个播客将模仿我最喜欢的播客之一——Magic Read-Along，那基本上就是两个家伙连线，听起来像是打了个电话，聊一些编程相关的事，也有一些不相关的。希望对于听众来说会很有趣。
Yeah, it's funny. That term algorithms plus data structures equals programs. It was actually one of the first things that my mentor, Hartmut Kaiser, told me about. And I don't think he ever mentioned the book to me, but he just said something to me in a moment of like, programming is just algorithms plus data structures. And Hartmut was this East German guy with this... he had a real character to him so he just said it in such a way as if it was just this fundamental truth of the universe and uh something i always really took to heart when did you learn that it was a book so also for those that aren't aware uh that what
对，这很有意思。“算法加数据结构等于程序”这个说法，其实是我的导师哈特穆特·凯泽（Hartmut Kaiser）跟我提过的第一批事情之一。我觉得他从来没跟我提过那本书，他只是在某个时刻随口对我说，编程就是算法加数据结构。哈特穆特是个东德人，很有个性……他说话的那种语气，就好像那是宇宙间某种根本真理一样，这也是我一直铭记在心的一句话。你是什么时候知道那是一本书的？所以，同样对于那些不知道的人来说，布莱斯刚才说的那句话其实是尼古拉斯·维尔特（Nikolaus Wirth）一本书的书名，出版于……我甚至不知道是哪年，大概在 70 年代，我们俩后来都读过。坦白说，我觉得我们俩大概都还没读过它。我们只是觉得这是个很棒的播客名字。
bryce just said is the title of a nicholas verth book that was published i don't even know what year probably in the 70s which at some point both of us would read. Full disclosure, I don't think either of us have read it yet. We just thought it was a great podcast name. Yeah, I think I first learned about it when you told me about it. And I think prior to that, my only exposure to that title was Hurtment having mentioned it to me. And I think I had no idea that it was a book. I just thought it was a wise saying that he told me. Interesting. Yeah, that algorithms plus data structures equals programs. Yeah. So what are we going to be talking about today? We've got a question in mind. What's that question? That question is, what is your favorite algorithm? And I thought that the answer to this question was going to be
对，我想我第一次知道这事儿是听你说的。在此之前，我唯一接触到这个书名，就是哈特穆特跟我提过的那次。我当时根本不知道这是一本书，我只觉得那是他告诉我的一句至理名言。有意思。对，就是算法加数据结构等于程序。那么，我们今天要聊点什么呢？我们心里有个问题。什么问题？那个问题就是：你最喜欢的算法是什么？我本来以为这个问题的答案会非常简单，因为我以为我们俩会说出同一个算法——实际上就是把我们凑到一起的那个算法，也就是 transform reduce 或 map reduce。我得讲讲我是怎么认识康纳的故事。那是……天哪，那是哪一年？是 2018 年吗？严格来说，我们第一次说话是在 2018 年，没错。但那是你在用户组做演讲的时候吗？我第一次在湾区 C++ 用户组演讲是在 2019 年 1 月。但我是在 2018 年 8 月 5 日搬到硅谷的。
really easy because I thought both of us were going to say the same algorithm, the algorithm, in fact, that brought us together, which is transform reduce or map reduce. And I should give the story of how I met Conor. So it was, God, what year was it? Was it 2018? Technically, the first time that we talked was in 2018, yes. But was that when you gave the talk at the user group? The first time I spoke at the Bay Area C++ user group was in January of 2019. But I moved to the Silicon Valley on August 5th of 2018.
然后我记得大概是在 8 月 8 日或 9 日，我去了我参加的第一个 C++ 湾区用户组活动。然后……不过我还是觉得是 2019 年，因为那是我们真正相识的时候。那是我们真正了解彼此的时候，就是你做那个演讲的时候。所以对于那些不知道的人，我住在湾区，几年前我成了湾区 C++ 用户组的主要组织者之一，不过后来我从这个角色退下来了，因为我实在没有空闲时间。但在当时，我仍然是主要组织者之一。我们总是在寻找社区里的人来做演讲。我不记得是康纳来找的我，还是我去找的康纳。但康纳来做了这个演讲。我至今仍认为这是康纳做过的最好的演讲。他做这个演讲时，我记得当时它还叫《算法直觉》。如果你想看这个演讲的一个版本……我觉得最好的版本就是去观看 CppNow 2019 的那个版本，它赢得了最佳演讲者和最佳演讲，还拿了一堆奖项。它本质上是一个关于……关于一些 C++ 算法的演讲。
And then I believe it was like August 8th or 9th I went to my first C++ Bay Area user group. And yeah. I'm going to say it was 2019 though, because that was when we really met. That was when we really got to know each other, was when you gave that talk. So for those who don't know, I live in the Bay Area and a few years ago I sort of became one of the main organizers of the Bay Area's C++ user group, although I've since stepped away from that role because I have no free time. But at the time, I was still one of the main organizers. And we're always looking for people
我想主要是一个关于特定的一组 C++ 序列算法的演讲，这些算法在我心中分量很重，其中有一些被称为数值算法。在这个演讲期间，康纳特别兴奋的一点——康纳是一个非常有激情的主讲人——他特别兴奋的一点就是 TransformReduce。TransformReduce 这个算法，如果你不是 C++ 圈内人，你可能更熟悉它的另一个名字：MapReduce。所以这个想法是，它是一个算法，它接收一个输入的元素序列，然后它对这些元素应用两个操作。其中一个操作是转换（transformation），它获取某个函数并将其应用到每个元素上。然后，该转换的结果会被输入到一个归约操作（reduction operation）中。而归约操作只是一个接收两个输入并从中产生一个单一输出的操作。例如，加法就是一个归约操作。加法，你接收两个输入，你知道的，就是你要相加的那两个东西，然后它输出一个单一的值。
from the community to give talks. And I don't remember if Connor approached me or I approached Connor. But Connor came to give this talk. And I still think it is the best talk that Connor's ever given. And he gave this talk about, I think it was at the time, it was still called Algorithm Intuition. And if you want to see a version of this talk um the best version i think would be to go watch the uh the version that c++ now 2019 which won like best speaker and best talk and it won a bunch of awards um and it's essentially it's a talk about um uh some of the C++ algorithms.
而且它非常强大，在数据科学中被广泛使用……所以我不得不说，你知道的，康纳的演讲中真正建立起我们友谊的那部分，就是我当时觉得这是有史以来最好的演讲。那正处于我职业生涯的一个阶段，能让我留下深刻印象的演讲门槛非常高……比如你知道的，有时有些演讲，我只会觉得：嗯，这挺好，但谈不上有多棒。但我对什么是真正的伟大演讲已经有了这种直觉。而康纳当时坐在那里做这个演讲，我心里就想：天哪，这太棒了。我之所以觉得它棒的原因之一，在于他谈论的所有内容，正是我在谈论这些算法时会说到的东西。康纳当时并不知道，我其实就是那个在语言标准里写下其中许多算法规范的人。而康纳当时正在讨论它们的一些问题和局限性。当时我就想：哦天哪，这家伙太懂了。我当时兴奋极了。他在那次演讲的某个地方提到，TransformReduce 是他最喜欢的算法。而我……
I think primarily it's talk about a particular set of the C++ sequence algorithms that are near and dear to my heart, some of which are known as the numeric algorithms. And during this talk, one of the things that Connor was particularly excited about, and Connor's a very excited speaker, one of the things he was particularly excited about was TransformReduce. TransformReduce is an algorithm that, if you're not a C++ person, you might know it better
几年前我也做过一次演讲，讲的是为什么 TransformReduce 是我最喜欢的算法，因为它太强大、太万能了。你能用它做的事情实在太多了。但我认为我们已经确认，其实我们俩现在都不觉得 TransformReduce 是我们最喜欢的算法了。是这样吗？嗯，我很想听听你的……我知道之前我们讨论这个话题时，那是你的第一反应，然后我说：哦，好吧，当时内积（inner product）或 transform reduce 确实是我最喜欢的算法，但我现在不这么觉得了。这并不是因为我不再爱它了——它依然是个了不起的算法，依然在我前 N 名的榜单里——不过是的，我想我现在有了一个新的算法，而且我想你大概也有了一个新的算法。所以，呃，好吧，不不，我希望你先说。你先说。我刚才已经说了一大堆话了。我想听听、我想听听你现在最喜欢的算法是什么。
under the name of MapReduce. So the idea is that it's an algorithm where it takes an input sequence of items, and then it takes two operations that it applies to them. One of those operations is a transformation, which takes some function and applies it to each one of the elements. And then the result of that transformation gets fed into a reduction operation. And a reduction operation is just an operation which takes two inputs and it produces a single output from it. So, for example, plus is a reduction operation. Plus, you take two inputs, you know, the two things that you're going to add together,
好吧，那我首先要说的是，甚至在……你知道的，内积（inner product）这个词，对于那些对 C++ 不太熟悉的人来说——因为我猜随着时间推移，我们会吸引到一些非 C++ 开发者来听节目——内积是 C++11 的名字，可以说是它的前身。它们并不完全相同，因为 TransformReduce（这是一个并行算法）的约束略有不同。但我最初是通过“内积”这个名字了解并认识 TransformReduce 的，当时我还心想：哇，这名字真够烂的。然后过了一两周，我发现了 C++17 的版本，当时就觉得：哦天哪，这个名字好太多了。大多数 C++17 并行算法都是这种情况。但在内积之前，我最喜欢的算法大概是 `std::partition`，这个算法我好像从来没在演讲里提过或者怎么样。我就是喜欢它，因为它是一个线性的运行时间算法，具有某种排序的行为。我把 partition 视为一种谓词排序（predicate sort）。你传入一个谓词，然后它把所有符合该谓词的东西排在前面，不符合的排在后面。
and it produces a single value as the output. And it's very powerful it's used a lot in data science um and so i i had to say you know the thing about connor's talk that really that really built our friendship was i just thought it was like the best talk ever and this was at a point in my career where the bar for a talk to impress me was really high um like you you know, sometimes there'd be talks and I'd just be like, ah, this is good, but not, like, great. But I'd come to have this intuition about, like, what was truly a great talk. And Connor was sitting there and giving this talk
但它的运行时间是线性的，这真的是超级超级棒。所以我从 partition 到了 inner product，再到重命名后的版本 transform reduce，然后又到了一个在极少数语言中存在的新算法，叫做外积（outer product）。事实上，以“积”命名的算法家族，我简直是它们的超级粉丝。所以在这个家族中，存在着内积（也就是 transform reduce）、笛卡尔积（Cartesian product，在 Python 和 Ruby 等语言中有时直接简称为 product），以及外积。我还希望有一个我尚未发现的算法叫做三角形积（triangle product），我在 CppCon 2020 的演讲中提到过它，不过我们今天不在这里谈论这个。所以，我们来聊聊外积。哇，等一下，等一下。为什么我们不聊那个？我想知道什么是三角形积。嗯，这些节目本来应该是 20:30 分钟左右的……不过好吧，我会解释外积，然后三角形积其实只是它的一个微小变体。
and I just thought, boy, this was great. And one of the reasons I thought it was great was he was talking about all the things that I would talk about when talking about these algorithms. And Connor didn't know at the time, but I had been the person who had written the, the like specification in the language for a bunch of these algorithms. And Connor was talking about a bunch of the problems and the limitations with them. And I was like, oh my God, this dude gets it. And I was so excited. And he mentioned at some point in that talk that transform reduces his favorite algorithm. And I
但如果你熟悉的话——我们已经讨论过内积，也就是 transform reduce。笛卡尔积，对于那些不熟悉的听众来说，在简单情况下，你只是接收两个序列或两个范围。但在更复杂的情况下，你可以接收最多 n 个。它是一个可变参数数量的序列。基本上，你会为该列表中每个元素的组合创建所有可能的组合。所以如果你有两个列表，A、B、C，第二个列表是 1、2、3，你就会创建成对的元素：A1、A2、A3、B1、B2、B3，以及 C1、C2、C3。
had given a talk a few years ago about how transform reduces my favorite algorithm because it's so powerful, so versatile. There's so much stuff that you can do about it. But I think that we've determined that neither of us actually think transform reduces our favorite algorithms. Is that right? Well, I'm curious to hear what you're... I know when we spoke about this topic a while back, that was your initial thought and then i said oh well at the time inner product or transform reduce was my favorite algorithm uh but i don't think it is anymore and that's not because i don't love it it's still you know it's amazing algorithm it's still in my top whatever n um but yeah i think i have a new
非常直观。所以最后你会得到……如果你有两个不同长度的列表，因为它们不需要是相同的长度，如果你有多个列表，你最终会得到 $n \times n$ 对元素或元组。因此，如果我们只从两个列表、序列或范围的角度来思考笛卡尔积，你实际上可以将其可视化为二维数据结构，比如矩阵。所以在我有 ABC 和 1、2、3 的情况下……外积不是像笛卡尔积那样在单个列表中返回所有配对，而是返回一个列表的列表（list of lists）或范围的范围（range of ranges）。所以你基本上会得到一个包含所有这些配对的矩阵，只不过返回的不是配对——类似于内积或 transform reduce，你指定一个二元归约操作，该操作会应用到每一个配对上。因此，如果你有一个外积，通常现在 ABC 和 123 的情况就说不通了。但如果你有数字，你知道的，每个列表从 1 到 5，你可以应用乘法（multiplies）二元操作，然后你得到的表格就是一个乘法表。这在面向数组的编程范式中极其有用，当然，这也是我在 ADSP 播客中第一次提到 APL。
one now and i guess maybe you have a new one too. So, uh, yeah, well, no, no, I want you to go first. You go first. I just, I just said a bunch of words. I want to hear, I want to hear what your, your new favorite algorithm. Well,
我们可以为我们的听众发起一个饮酒游戏，每当我提到 APL（我最喜欢的编程语言）时就喝一杯。但外积，它基本上存在于每一个数组编程语言中，比如 APL、J，Julia 可能是人们听说过的最流行的数组编程语言。Haskell 也有外积。
so first I should say that even before, uh, you know, so inner product for, for those of you that, um, you know, are less familiar with C plus plus,
但我认为除此之外，这些就是我知道的拥有外积的仅有的几语言。不过你可以用它做出非常非常酷的事情。顺便补充一下，如果你有笛卡尔积却没有外积，你可以先做一个笛卡尔积，然后调用另一个名为 chunk（分块）的算法，你只需传入第一个序列的长度，然后对你的列表进行分块——也就是对笛卡尔积的结果列表进行分块——从而基本上得到与外积等价的效果。但这就是我最喜欢的算法。我太喜欢它了。也许 C++29 的 ranges 会引入它吧。我们走着瞧。不过布莱斯，你现在最喜欢的算法是什么？所以，我最喜欢的算法，为了理解它……不过布莱斯，我最喜欢的算法其实讲述的是我职业生涯开端的故事。所以它实际上完美契合我们的第一期播客以及我最喜欢的算法。嗯……我会说，它是该算法的一个特定实现，因为这引入了那个故事，也就是 `boost::algorithm::split`。而这个……原因之一、也是它成为我最喜欢的原因之一是，这是我第一次接触到 Boost。所以在 2010 年，我是一个刚进大学不久就辍学的人……好吧，严格来说我不是辍学，严格来说我是挂科被开除的，如果我们实话实说的话。这是因为我对学校感到厌烦，而且我……小时候玩过很多基于文本的游戏，叫做 MUD。
cause I imagine we're going to have some non C plus plus developers listening in over time. Um, inner product is the C plus plus 11 name, sort of the precursor. It's not identical because the constraints on the TransformReduce, which is a parallel algorithm, are slightly different. But I sort of first learned of TransformReduce by the name Interproduct, and then I thought to myself, wow, this is a really bad name. And then like a couple weeks later, discovered the C++17 version,
我开始学编程就是为了创建我自己的 MUD 引擎。在开始之前我对编程一无所知。当时我和一个程序员小伙子一起合作。我们是用 C++ 做的，这在当时有点新颖，因为许多 MUD 都是用 C 语言写的。但他当时说：“对，我们应该用 C++。它更新潮，更好。”于是我通过这个项目第一次接触到了标准库。然后在这个 MUD 引擎里有一个地方，他正在使用 Boost，具体来说，他使用的是 `boost::algorithm::split`。那个 split 算法是什么呢，它其实就是一个基础的分词（tokenization）算法。
was like, oh my gosh, this is way better name. And that's the case with most of the C++17 parallel algorithms. But before Interproduct, probably my favorite algorithm was std partition, which I don't think I've ever said in a talk or anything. I just loved it because it was a linear runtime algorithm that had sort of the behavior of a sort. I think of partition as like a predicate sort. You pass a predicate and then you sort everything that adheres to it at the beginning and doesn't adhere to it at the end.
所以你给它一个输入序列，然后你给它一些 token（分隔符/标记）。它获取输入序列并使用这些 token 将其切碎。比如，你知道的，如果你有一个 IP 地址，并且你想把它拆分成单独的数字组件，你的 token 就是一个句点（`.`）。然后，你知道的，如果我有 IP 地址 127.0.0.1 并把它输入到这个分词算法中，
But it's a linear runtime, which is super, super nice. So I went from partition to inner product to the renamed version, transform reduce, to then a new algorithm, which exists in very few languages, called outer product. And in fact, the product,-unquote family of algorithms, I'm just a huge fan of.
它会给我返回四个组件：第一个组件是 127，第二个是 0，第三个是 0，最后一个是 1。我不记得我们在那个小 MUD 引擎里具体用它来做什么了，我想我们可能是用它来……也许是用它来把输入到 MUD 中的命令拆分成它们的组成部分。但那是我的我第一次接触 Boost，而且我依稀记得，我在该算法中发现了某种 Bug，于是我去找 Boost 社区的人，跟他们说：“嘿，这里有个 Bug，我有个修复方案。”然后我非常迅速地从我的小游戏项目完全分心出来，开始为 Boost 做贡献。如果我没记错的话，发生的事情是我的用例变得越来越高级。
So in that family exists inner product, otherwise known as transform reduce, Cartesian product, which is sometimes just known as product in languages like Python and Ruby, and outer product. And I also wish that there was an algorithm that I have yet to discover called triangle product, which I mentioned in my CppCon 2020 talk,
然后有人对我说：“你应该用 Boost Spirit。”接着我开始和 Boost Spirit 的那帮人交流，并开始为 Boost Spirit 贡献代码。当时，你知道的，Boost Spirit 的主要贡献者之一是它的创始人之一，哈特穆特·凯泽（Hartmut Kaiser）。因此我认识了哈特穆特。过了一段时间后，我和哈特穆特开始聊起……
but we're not going to talk about that here. So outer product. Whoa, whoa, whoa. Why aren't we going to talk about that? I want to know what triangle product is. Well, these things are supposed to be like 20 to 30 minutes. But yeah, so I'll explain outer product and then triangle product is just a slight variation of it.
其实是我在 IRC 上主动找他，对他说：“嘿，我需要一份工作，”因为我当时是个 19 岁的大学辍学生。他说：“那你买张去路易斯安那州的单程机票，下来这里为我工作吧。”我父母当然绝对讨厌这个主意——让我坐上飞机去找一个他们从未见过的陌生人。我妈当时觉得他可能是个连环杀手。
But so if you're familiar, so we've discussed inner product, a.k.a. transform reduce. Cartesian product, for those of you that aren't familiar, is basically in the simple case you're taking two sequences or two ranges. But in the more complicated, you can take up to n. It's a variadic number of sequences. And basically you create all possible combinations of each of the elements in that list. So if you have two lists, A, B, C, and then the second list is 1, 2, 3, you create the pairs of elements A1, A2, A3, B1, B2, B3, and C1, C2, C3.
而这就是我职业生涯的起点。你妈妈会听这个播客吗？哦，她可能会听这个播客。是的。对，但我认为这是一个非常酷的算法。而它之所以是个非常酷的算法的原因之一，是因为这是许多程序员经常会遇到的非常普遍的问题。即使你没有做那么复杂的事情，我认为分词也是一个相当常见的事情。我的意思是，即使你只是在写一些命令行脚本，这也是一件很常见的事情：嘿，我有这个输入序列，
Pretty straightforward. So you end up with like, if you have two different length lists, because they don't need to be the same length, you end up with n times n pairs or tuples of elements if you have more than two lists. So a Cartesian product, if we think about it just in sort of the two list or sequence or range case, you can actually visualize that as a two-dimensional data structure, like a matrix. So in the case where I had ABC and 1, 2, 3,
我需要用某种方式把它分割开来。而且这也……它引出了一些关于效率的有趣讨论。你知道的，我们在 C++17 中引入 `std::string_view` 的原因之一，就是为了允许你更高效地编写像这样的算法。让我们回到解析 IP 地址的那个例子。假设我有一个存储某个 IP 地址的字符串，具体来说是一个 `std::string`。我想把这个 `std::string` 拆分成它的各个组成部分。所以 `std::string` 是一个拥有所有权的字符串。
instead of just a Cartesian product gives you back all of the pairs in a single list, outer product gives you back a list of lists or a range of ranges. So you end up with basically a matrix that has each of these pairs, except instead of getting back pairs, similar to inner product or transform reduce, you specify a binary reduction operation that is applied to each of those pairs. So if you have an outer product, typically now the ABC123 case doesn't make sense. But if you have the numbers, you know, one to five for each list, you can apply the multiplies binary operation, and then your resulting table is a multiplication table. And this is extremely useful in the array oriented programming paradigm, which of course, is where the first time on the ADSP, the podcast, I'll be mentioning APL.
你知道的，它拥有它所指向的字符串的内存。所以，如果我的 split API 的设计是它接收一个 `std::string` 并返回一个 `std::string` 的 `vector`，那么，天哪，这可真是一点都不高效，对吧？因为我所做的是，我拿着这个初始的输入字符串，对于每一个组成部分，我都必须复制那段字符串，然后把它塞进我将要返回的 `vector` 中。因此，为什么 C++17 的 `string_view` 很有用的经典例子之一就是 split。因为如果我有一个 `string_view`，`string_view` 是什么呢？它是一个对其他字符串的非所有权视图（non-owning view）。所以如果我有一个作为输入字符串的字符串，
We can start potentially a drinking game for our listeners every time I mention APL, which is my favorite programming language. But outer product, it exists in basically every array programming language, APL, J, Julia is probably the most popular array programming language that people have heard of. Haskell also has an outer product.
并且我想把它拆分成各个组成部分，`string_view` 对此简直完美，因为 `string_view` 不拥有所有权。它只需要引用它所指的那段字符串即可。而该字符串的存储空间是由原始输入拥有的。因此，与其返回一个 string，
But I think other than those, those are the only languages that I know that have outer product. But you can do very, very cool things. And just to add, if you have Cartesian product and you don't have outer product, you can do a Cartesian product and then call another algorithm called chunk, where you just pass the length of the first sequence and then chunk your list, the resulting list from your Cartesian product to get basically the equivalent of an outer product. But that's my favorite algorithm. I absolutely love it. And maybe C++29 ranges will get it. We'll see. What is your favorite algorithm now though, Bryce? So my favorite algorithm, to understand it, my favorite algorithm actually though, Bryce? So my favorite algorithm to understand it,
你完全可以返回一个 `string_view` 的 `vector`，或者甚至比 `vector` 更好的东西。而且这实际上更加有趣，因为就在本周，我的另一项工作是担任 C++ 委员会库设计组的主席，我们本周收到了一篇关于改进 C++ 中字符串分割的提案。C++20 引入了 ranges（范围），这是一种比我们以前基于迭代器的惯用法更强大的编写算法的范式。C++20 中引入的东西之一就是一个名为 `split_view` 的 ranges 视图。但 `split_view` 存在一点小问题。
my favorite algorithm actually tells the story of the start of my career. So it's actually like perfect for our first podcast and my favorite algorithm. Um, uh, I will, I will say it's a specific implementation of the algorithm because that leads into the story, which is boost algorithm split. And this, and the reason, well, one of the reasons that this is my favorite is this was the first algorithm, the first time I was ever exposed to boost. So back in 2010, I was a fresh college dropout okay technically speaking i didn't drop out of college technically speaking i flunked out and they kicked me out for if we're if we're being correct about things and um it was because i was bored with school and i um i played a lot of text based games called muds when I was a kid.
而这篇论文试图解决这个问题。问题在于 C++20 中的 `split_view`，你给它一个序列，它会返回给你一个序列的序列。问题是那个序列的序列给你的迭代器是什么类型的。所以我从提案中了解到的情况是，目前你从 `split_view` 获得的迭代器仅提供前向迭代器保证（forward iterator guarantee）。这带来了问题，因为几乎所有的字符串 API 都期望连续迭代器（contiguous iterator）。假设你采用 C++20 的 split，
And I started learning programming to create my own MUD engine. And I didn't know anything about programming before I started this. I was working with this guy who was a programmer. And we were doing it in C++, which was sort of novel because a lot of MUDs were written in C. But he was like, yeah, we should do C++. It's more of novel because a lot of MUDs were written in C, but he was like, yeah, we should use C++. It's more modern. It's better. And so I first got exposed to the standard library in this project. And then there was one place in this MUD engine where he was using Boost and it was, he was using Boost algorithm split. And what that split algorithm is, is it's just a basic tokenization algorithm.
并且你想做类似解析 IP 地址的事情，然后你想调用 C 库函数 `atoi`，或者来自 `from_chars` 的更现代版本，将这些 IP 的各个组成部分转换为真正的整数类型。但你做不到，因为 split 给你的迭代器不是传给 `from_chars` 的正确迭代器类型，它们也不是传给 `from_chars` 的正确迭代器类型，而且它们也不是转换并传给 `atoi` 的正确迭代器类型，因为 `atoi` 期望的是真正的指针。所以有一个提案——天哪，我记不得提案编号了，我确信，我确信我们可以把它加上去，
So you give it an input sequence and then you give it some set of tokens. And it takes the input sequence and it chops it up using those tokens. So like, you know, if you had an IP address and you wanted to split it out into the individual numeric components, your token would be a period. And then what, you know, if I had the IP address 127.0.0.1 and I fed it into this tokenization algorithm,
我们会把它放进节目文稿中。我们会把它放进节目大纲里。是的，我们会把它放进节目大纲里。《Superior String Splitting》是这篇论文的名字。来吧，我看看能不能找到它。但这个提案本质上旨在解决这个问题。来吧，我拿到论文编号了。
it would give me back four components the first component would be one two seven then second one would be zero the third one would be zero the last one would be one um and i don't remember exactly what we were using it for in this little mud engine i think we were using it to perhaps we were using it to like um uh separate out um commands entered into the mud into into their constituent components but it was my first exposure to boost and i seem to recall i found some sort of bug in the algorithm and so i went to the boost people and i was like hey here's this bug i had this fix for it um and then i very rapidly got completely sidelined from my little game project into contributing to Boost. And if I recall correctly, what happened was my use case got more and more advanced.
这是 Barry Revzin 提出的 P2210。而那个 IP 的例子就是论文里的第一个例子。所以如果你去看那篇论文，你就会立刻明白我的意思。这个提案试图在 C++ 中补救这一点，使 `split_view` 在处理字符串时更加有用。另一个算法，我认为它某种程度上与这个相关，就是用分隔符连接一组字符串的算法。我们大家可能都在某个时刻写过这个。你知道的，你有一个字符串 `vector`，你想在它们中间插入逗号。我确信我们都写过那种朴素的形式，就是你有一个 `for` 循环，它只是做……
And somebody was like, you should use Boost Spirit. And then I started talking with the Boost Spirit guys and I started contributing to Boost Spirit. And at the time, you know, one of the main contributors to Boost Spirit was one of its creators, Hartmut Kaiser. And so I got to know Hartmut. And after, you know, some period of time, Hartmut and I got talking about,
比如，你知道的，“如果我是第一个，那就不要插入”，等等。但你大概能告诉我那个算法的名字是什么。我甚至其实都不知道那个算法在……你知道的，那些酷炫算法的语言里叫什么名字。你刚才描述的那个变体是什么？就像它在每个元素之间插入一个逗号，但是……比如它不会在第一个元素之前或最后一个元素之后插入一个……那取决于语言，但通常这被称为……它也在做拼接对吧？对对对，它也在做……所以通常那是——有几种不同的名字，但对吧，`join`（连接）、`concat`（拼接）或 `flatten`（扁平化）通常不接受分隔符。我知道在 Haskell 中有一个算法叫做 `intersperse`，它和 `join` 做的事一样，但是……减去连接操作。所以如果你有一个元素列表，它只会在每个元素之间插入你想要的那个新元素，但不会把它们连起来。
well, I basically approached him on IRC and was like, hey, I need a job because I was like a 19-year-old college dropout. And he's like, why don't you buy a one-way plane ticket to Louisiana, come down here and work for me. My parents, of course, absolutely loved this idea of me getting on a plane and going off to some stranger that they'd never met. My mother thought he was going to be an axe murderer.
所以你最后得到的仍然是一个元素列表。但我想通常……它叫什么？它叫 `intersperse`？`intersperse`，是的。有两个不同的 inter 算法。一个是 `intersperse`？`intersperse`，是的。有两个不同的 inter 算法。一个是 `intersperse`，另一个是 `interleave`（交织）。顺便说个 C++ 的小冷知识，如果你看过 Eric Niebler 的演讲——他是 RangeV3 库的作者，该库的工作旨在展示 C++ ranges 的样貌——在他的关于 calendar（日历）的演讲中，我相信那是 CppCon 2015，误差正负一年吧……他展示了一个用于转置（transposing）的算法，这其实就是
And that was the start of my career. Is your mom going to listen to this podcast? Oh, she'll probably listen to this podcast. Yes. Yeah. But I think it's a very cool algorithm. And one of the reasons why it's a very cool algorithm is it's a very common thing that comes up for a lot of programmers. Even if you're not doing anything like that complex, I think tokenization is a fairly common thing to come up. I mean, even if you're just writing some command line scripts, it's a very common thing that you do where you're like, hey, I have this input sequence
`chunk` 和 `interleave` 的组合。`interleave` 指的是基本上你有 n 个不同的序列，然后你从每个序列中一次取一个元素，这样你就以这种方式重新排序了它们；然后你去从每一个序列中取第二个元素，以此类推。然后你去从每个算法中取第二个元素，诸如此类。但对吧，`join`，我认为这是它的一个经典名字。有趣的是，我们在 C++20 ranges 中获得的 `join` 不接受分隔符。所以在当前的 C++23 提案中，为了扩展 range 算法和适配器（顺便说一下，应该叫视图），我们不得不提出带有分隔符的 `join`，因为不幸的是我们设计 `join` 的方式不允许我们扩展接口，
and I need to divide it up in some way. And it also, it sort of leads into some interesting discussions about efficiency. You know, one of the reasons that we introduced StringView into C++17 was to allow you to write an algorithm like this more efficiently. So let's go back to that example of parsing an IP address. Let's say that I've got a string that stores some IP address, a std string specifically. And I want to split that std string up into its constituent components. So a std string is an
使其能够接受分隔符。所以我们现在需要为此使用两个不同的算法，这……这会不会是你在演讲中要展示的另一个例子？你会在演讲中列出每种编程语言对它的称呼，而且每种编程语言叫法都一样，故意……我指的是 C++ 把所有语言都叫作 `map` 的东西叫作 `std::transform`——因为我们不小心已经为我们的有序关联容器和有序的……对，所以这真的是个问题——就像人们认为名字可能不重要一样，但我敢打赌，你知道的，这个演讲的前半部分，我们一直在讨论 transform reduce。我敢打赌，我们的许多观众其实并不知道 transform reduce 是什么。
owning string. You know, it owns the memory for the string that it points to. So if my API for split is that it takes a std string in and it returns a vector of std strings, well, boy, that is not efficient at all, is it? Because then what I'm doing is I'm taking this one initial input string, and for each one of the constituent components, I have to make a copy of that piece of the string and stick it into the vector that I'm going to return. And so one of the canonical examples for why C++17 string view is useful is split. Because if I have a string view, what a string view is, is it's a non-owning view into some other string. So if I have one string that's my input string,
但如果我们说……我们确实说过 map reduce。你知道的，如果你说 map reduce，更多的人会知道，因为在所有其他语言里它都叫这个名字。而且，不仅如此。不仅是 Transform 在其他语言中被称为 Map，而且 MapReduce 本身就是一个特定的范式。所以我们把 Map 叫作 Transform 的错误，进而导致了另一个错误：MapReduce 这种常见范式在 C++ 中不叫 MapReduce。而且这个问题反过来也存在。所以我以前听说过 MapReduce 以及整个 Hadoop，你知道的，在大规模下进行这种计算。而且我认为 MapReduce，你知道的，
and I want to split it up into the constituent components, string view is perfect for this because the string view is non-owning. It can just refer to the piece of the string that it refers to. And the storage for that string is owned by the original input. And so instead of returning a string view,
在 Google 变得非常流行有一段时间，或者现在可能依然如此。我当时以为它跟我学到的 TransformReduce 不同，而且我直到开始学习函数式编程之前，从来没有把它们联系起来……所以，是的，这对于 C++ 开发者来说是个问题——把事情与……你知道的，其他语言或范式中的概念联系起来；对于来到 C++ 的软件开发者来说也是如此。不过，命名确实很难。好吧，这就触及到了……你知道的，其中一个原因——我刚才没有真正解释为什么我这么喜欢 Transform Reduce，但原因
you can return a vector of string views or perhaps even something better than a vector. And it's actually even more interesting because just coincidentally, this week, one of my other jobs is I'm the chair of the C++ Committee's Library Design Group. And we got a paper this week talking about improving string splitting in C++. So C++20 introduced ranges, which is a more powerful idiom for composing algorithms than our previous idiom, which was iterator-based. And one of the things that's introduced in C++20 is a ranges view called split view. But there's kind of a little bit of a problem with split view.
在于，你比我更懂算法。我更像是一个系统软件方面的人，但实际上我的专业和专长在于并行编程和并发编程。我在 NVIDIA 的工作之一是担任 Thrust 的团队负责人，Thrust 是我们的并行算法库，也就是我们对 C++17 并行算法的实现。我认为 transform reduce 是所有并行算法中最有用的。我稍微缓和一下这个说法。我会说 reduce 是最有用的算法之一。我这么说是因为在我们的实现中，我们是用其他算法来实现许多算法的。而最多算法基于其来实现的底层算法就是 reduce 和 transform reduce。你知道的，诸如极值函数（`min_element`、`max_element`）、`count_if` 等等。在我们的并行算法库中，所有这些都是通过 reduction 和 transform reduce 来实现的。
And this paper tries to address it. The problem is split view in C++20, you give it some sequence and it gives you back a sequence of sequences. The issue is what type of iterators that sequence of sequence gives you. So my understanding from the proposal is that today the iterators that you get back from split view only provide the forward iterator guarantee. And this is problematic because almost all of the string API's expect contiguous iterator. So suppose that you're taking C++20 split
总的来说，它就是一个非常实用的并行算法。是的，正如 Ben Dean 在一次演讲中所说——跳出并行世界来看——Ben Dean 在 2016 年的 CPPCon 上做过一个名为《`std::accumulate`：一个算法帝国》的演讲，他在演讲中展示了横跨几个头文件的 90 个算法中，有 77 个
and you wanna do something like parse an IP address and then you wanna call the C library function A2I, or the more modern version from cars, to convert each one of those IP constituent components to an actual integer type. But you can't do that because the iterators that split gives you are not the correct type of iterators to feed into from cars, and they're not the correct type of iterators to feed into from cars and and they're not the correct type of iterators to turn into to give to a to I because a to I expects actual you know pointers so there's this proposal oh god I'm not gonna remember the proposal number I'm sure I'm sure sure we can add
只要稍微扭曲和变形一下，就可以完全用 `std::accumulate` 来实现。而 `std::accumulate` 基本上就是 C++11 标准对 `std::reduce` 的称呼——当然，由于 reduce 算法的并行特性，它们在限制上还是有微小差异的。但你会开始到处看到 reduction（归约）。我还记得当我收听第一期 LambdaCast 播客时，他们在讨论 map、reduce 和 filter。他们谈到了什么是 katamorphic 函数（折叠函数）和 anamorphic 函数（展开函数）。Katamorphic 函数就是那些执行归约的函数。
it in we'll put it in the show post. We'll put it in the show notes. Yeah, we'll put it in the show notes. Superior String Splitting is the name of the paper. Here, I'll see if I can find it. But this proposal essentially aims to fix this problem. Here, I got the paper
Anamorphic 正好就是 split。也就是你获取一个列表，然后最终得到一个列表的列表。所以像 `chunk`、`split`、`group_by`，它们全都是 anamorphic 函数的变体。但这些分类简直无处不在。一旦你了解了它们，一切看起来都像是归约。我想有一篇论文叫《优美的折叠（Beautiful Folds）》，里面展示了基本上所有东西都可以用归约来实现。我想有一篇论文叫《优美的折叠》，里面展示了基本上所有东西都可以用归约来实现。是的，我制作了一张非常棒的图表，展示了我们的并行算法层中，各个算法之间是通过哪些其他算法来实现的依赖关系。我刚刚在屏幕上把它分享给你了。
number. It's P2210 by Barry Rebson. And that IP example is like the first example in the paper. So if you go and look at that paper, you'll see immediately what I mean. And this proposal attempts to remedy that in C++ to make the split view a lot more useful when working with strings. And the other algorithm, which is, I think, sort of combined with this, is the algorithm for joining a set of strings with a delimiter. We've all probably written this at some point. You know, you have a vector of strings, and you want to insert a comma in between them. And I'm sure we've all written the naive form of this where you've just got some for loop and it just does
编号。这是 Barry Rebson 提出的 P2210。那个 IP 的例子就像是论文里的第一个例子。所以如果你去看看那篇论文，你就会立刻明白我的意思。这个提案试图在 C++ 中补救这一点，使得在处理字符串时，split 视图更加有用。另一个算法，我认为它某种程度上与这个相结合，就是用分隔符将一组字符串连接起来的算法。我们大家可能都在某个时候写过这个。你知道的，你有一个字符串 vector，你想在它们之间插入一个逗号。我确信我们都写过这种最朴素的形式，你只需要写一个循环，然后它就会
like, you know, if I'm the first one, then don't insert it, et cetera. But you could probably tell me if there's like what the name of that algorithm is. I don't even actually know what the name of that algorithm is in like, you know, all the cool kid algorithm languages. What's the variant that you just described? It's like where it inserts a comma in between every element, but like not, it doesn't insert one before the first element or after the last element uh that depends on the language but like typically that is called um it's doing the concatenation as well right right right it's also doing so typically that is like there's several different names but yeah join uh concat or flatten typically don't take a delimiter i know in haskell there's an algorithm called intersperse which is the same thing as join, but like minus the concatenation. So like if you have a list of elements, it will just insert in between every element the new element that you want there, but like doesn't join them.
比如，你知道的，如果我是第一个元素，那么就不要插入它，诸如此类。但你大概能告诉我那个算法的名字是什么。我甚至实际上不知道在所有那些炫酷的算法语言中，那个算法的名字叫什么。你刚才描述的那个变体是什么？就像它在每个元素之间插入一个逗号，但是，它不会在第一个元素之前或最后一个元素之后插入一个...这取决于语言，但通常这被称为...它同时也做连接，对吧？对对对，它也做了连接。所以通常那种操作有几种不同的名字，但是是的，join、concat 或 flatten 通常不带分隔符。我知道在 Haskell 中有一个算法叫做 intersperse，它和 join 是同一回事，但是去掉了连接。所以如果你有一个元素列表，它只会把你想放的新元素插入到每个元素之间，但不会把它们连接起来。
So you still end up with a list of elements. But I think typically... What's it called? It's called intersperse? Intersperse, yeah. There's two different inter algorithms. One is intersperse? Intersperse, yeah. There's two different inter-algorithms. One is intersperse, and one is interleave. And a little C++
所以你最后得到的仍然是一个元素列表。但我想通常...它叫什么？它叫 intersperse？Intersperse，是的。有两个不同的 inter 算法。一个是 intersperse？Intersperse，是的。有两个不同的 inter 算法。一个是 intersperse，另一个是 interleave。还有一个小小的 C++
trivia fact, if you've watched Eric Niebler, who is the author behind the RangeV3 library, which was the work that was sort of done to show what C++ ranges could look like, in his calendar talk, i believe it was cpp con 2015 but i plus or minus one uh he shows an algorithm for transposing which is just a
冷知识，如果你看过 Eric Niebler 的演讲，他是 RangeV3 库的作者，这项工作旨在展示 C++ ranges 的可能样貌。在他的关于日历的演讲中，我相信那是 2015 年的 CppCon，误差正负一年吧，他展示了一种用于转置的算法，这其实只是
composition of chunk and interleave interleave being where basically you have n different sequences and then you take one element at a time from each one uh so that you reorder them that way um and then you go and take the second element from each one so that you reorder them that way. And then you go and take the second element from each algorithm, so on and so forth. But yeah, join, I think it's a classic name for it. Interestingly, the join that we got in ranges C++20 doesn't take a delimiter. So in the current C++23 proposal for sort of extending the range algorithms and adapters, I should say, and views we've had to propose join with, because unfortunately the way we design join doesn't enable us to extend the
chunk 和 interleave 的组合。interleave 的意思是，基本上你有 n 个不同的序列，然后每次从每个序列中取出一个元素，这样你就可以用这种方式重新排序它们...然后你去从每个算法中取出第二个元素，以此类推。不过是的，join，我认为这是一个很经典的命名。有趣的是，我们在 C++20 ranges 中得到的 join 是不带分隔符的。所以在当前的 C++23 提案中，为了扩展 range 算法和适配器（我应该这么说）以及 views，我们不得不提出带分隔符的 join，因为不幸的是我们设计 join 的方式无法让我们扩展
interface such that it can take a delimiter. So we now need two different algorithms for that, which. Is this going to be another example that you're going to show in a talk where you're going to have a list of what every programming language calls it, and it's going to be the same for every programming language, andly referring to is the fact that c++ calls uh what every language calls map um stood transform uh because we accidentally already chose map for our uh ordered associative containers and ordered um yeah so that that and this this is a real problem like like people think that names might not matter, but I bet you, you know, the first half of this talk, we talked about transform reduce. And I bet you that a lot of our audience would have not really known what transform reduce is.
这个接口使其能够接受一个分隔符。所以我们现在为此需要两个不同的算法，这...这会是你在演讲中要展示的另一个例子吗？你会列出一个清单，展示每种编程语言对它的称呼，而且每种语言叫法都一样...我真正指的是，C++ 把其他所有语言都叫 map 的东西称为... std::transform，因为我们不小心已经为我们的有序关联容器和有序...嗯...所以那个...这确实是个问题，就像人们认为名字可能不重要，但我敢打赌，你知道的，在这场演讲的前半部分，我们谈到了 transform reduce。我敢打赌我们的很多观众其实并不知道 transform reduce 是什么。
But if we said, you know, we did say map reduce. You know, if you say map reduce, a lot more people know that because that's what it's called in every other language. And, like, it's not only that. It's not only that Transform is called Map in every other language, it's that MapReduce is a specific paradigm. So our mistake of calling MapTransform then led to this other mistake of the common paradigm of MapReduce not being called MapReduce in C++. And the problem also exists in reverse. So I had heard of MapReduce and the whole Hadoop, you know, at scale doing this kind of computation. And I think MapReduce, you know,
但如果我们说，你知道的，我们确实说过 map reduce。你知道的，如果你说 map reduce，会有更多人知道，因为那是它在所有其他语言中的名字。而且，不仅如此。不仅是 transform 在所有其他语言中被称为 map，而且 map reduce 本身就是一个特定的范式。所以我们把 map 称为 transform 的错误，进而导致了另一个错误，即 map reduce 这个常见范式在 C++ 中不被称为 map reduce。而且这个问题也反过来存在。所以我听说过 map reduce 和整个 Hadoop，你知道的，在大规模下做这种计算。而且我认为 map reduce，你知道的，
became very popular at Google for a while, or maybe still is. And I thought it was different than what, like I learned TransformReduce and like never made the connection until i started learning functional programming um and so like yeah it's it's both a problem for c++ developers uh relating things to you know in other languages or paradigms um and also for you know software developers coming to c++ um but yeah naming naming is hard well and that sort of gets to, you know, one of the reasons why, I didn't explain really why I like Transform Reduce so much, but the reason
在 Google 非常流行了一段时间，或者现在可能依然如此。我以为它和我所学的 transform reduce 不同，并且直到我开始学习函数式编程之前，我从来没有把它们联系起来。所以，是的，这对于 C++ 开发者来说是个问题，他们在把事物与其他语言或范式联系起来时会遇到困难，对于来到 C++ 的软件开发者来说也是如此。不过，命名确实很难。好吧，这就引出了...你知道的，其中一个原因，我没有真正解释为什么我那么喜欢 transform reduce，但原因在于
is, you know, you're much more an algorithms guy than me. I'm more of a system software sort of guy, but really my expertise and specialty is in parallel programming and concurrent programming. And one of my jobs at NVIDIA is I'm the team lead for Thrust, which is our parallel algorithms library, our implementation of C++17 parallel algorithms. And I think transform-reduce is the most useful of the parallel algorithms. I'll temper that a little bit. I'll say that reduce is one of the most useful. And I say that because in our implementation, we implement many algorithms in terms of other algorithms. And the algorithm that the most number of algorithms are implemented in terms of is reduce and transform reduce. You know, there's things like the extrema functions, you know, min element, max element, count if, et cetera. All of those are implemented in terms of reductions and transform reduce in our parallel algorithms library.
你比我更懂算法。我更倾向于系统软件方面的人，但实际上我的专业领域和专长是并行编程和并发编程。我在 NVIDIA 的工作之一是担任 Thrust 的团队负责人，这是我们的并行算法库，是我们对 C++17 并行算法的实现。我认为 transform reduce 是所有并行算法中最有用的。我稍微缓和一下这个说法。我会说 reduce 是最有用的之一。我这么说是因为在我们的实现中，我们通过其他算法来实现许多算法。而被最多算法用来实现自身的算法就是 reduce 和 transform reduce。你知道的，有一些函数比如极值函数，min element、max element、count if 等等。在我们的并行算法库中，所有这些都是通过 reduction 和 transform reduce 来实现的。
And in general, it's just a very useful parallel algorithm. Yep, there was a talk given by, you know, moving outside the parallel world, a talk that Ben Dean gave, I believe it was at 2016 CPPCon, called Stood Accumulate, an Alg an algorithmic empire where he showed that of the 90 algorithms across a couple headers 77 of
总的来说，它就是一个非常实用的并行算法。是的，有一场演讲是由...跳出并行世界来看，Ben Dean 在 2016 年的 CppCon 上发表过一场演讲，名为《std::accumulate：一个算法帝国》（Stood Accumulate, an Algorithmic Empire），他在演讲中展示了在跨越几个头文件的 90 个算法中，有 77 个
them with a little bit of sort of bending and twisting were implementable in terms of std accumulate which is what the C++11 standard calls basically std reduce once again slight differences on restrictions due to the parallel nature of the reduce algorithm but yeah you start to see reductions everywhere. I remember when I listened to the first LambdaCast podcast where they were talking about sort of maps, reduces, and filters. And they were talking about how like there's catamorphic functions and anamorphic functions. Catamorphic functions are the ones that do reductions.
通过稍微的变通和扭曲，都可以用 std::accumulate 来实现。这就是 C++11 标准基本上所称的 std::reduce（当然，由于 reduce 算法的并行特性，在限制上再次存在微小的差异）。但是，是的，你开始到处看到 reduction。我记得当我听第一期 LambdaCast 播客时，他们谈到了 map、reduce 和 filter。他们谈到了什么是 catamorphic 函数和 anamorphic 函数。Catamorphic 函数就是那些执行 reduction 的函数。
Anamorphic is exactly split. So it's when taking a list and you end up with a list of lists. So like chunk, split, group by, they're all versions of anamorphic ones. But like these categories are just everywhere. And that like once you learn them, everything starts to look like a reduction. I think there's a paper called Beautiful Folds where they show that like basically everything is implementable in terms of a reduction. I think there's a paper called Beautiful Folds where they show that basically everything is implementable in terms of a reduction. Yeah, I have this great diagram that I made that shows the dependencies between which algorithms are implemented in terms of other algorithms in our parallel algorithms layer. And I just shared it with you on my screen,
Anamorphic 正好就是 split。也就是当你拿一个列表，最后得到一个列表的列表。比如 chunk、split、group by，它们都是 anamorphic 的版本。但这些分类简直无处不在。一旦你学会了它们，一切都开始看起来像是一个 reduction。我想有一篇论文叫做《美丽的折叠》（Beautiful Folds），他们在文中展示了基本上所有东西都可以用 reduction 来实现。我想有一篇论文叫做《美丽的折叠》，他们在文中展示了基本上所有东西都可以用 reduction 来实现。是的，我有一个自己制作的很棒的图表，展示了我们的并行算法层中，哪些算法是通过其他算法来实现的，它们之间的依赖关系。我刚刚在屏幕上分享给你看了
although it's not great for the podcast audience. I was going to say now, now you know what this means. We're going to have to start screen capturing and putting these on YouTube as well, because now our listeners are going to feel left out that we're staring at their screens and they're not. Plus you need, you need, you need the pictures, like the video evidence of how excitable we get. But yeah, it's really fascinating some of the things that are implemented with reductions in thrust. So findif is one whole family of algorithms that we implement in terms of reductions. In parallel algorithms, oftentimes short-circuiting algorithms or algorithms where you can give up early, it doesn't make sense to do those in our implementation. Well, give up is a bit of a misnomer. You've already found your results, so you can stop iterating.
虽然这对播客观众来说不太好。我本来想说，现在你知道这意味着什么了。我们得开始录屏并把这些发到YouTube上了，因为我们的听众现在会觉得自己被冷落了，因为我们在盯着他们的屏幕而他们没有。而且你需要图片，比如我们有多兴奋的视频证据。不过说真的，使用thrust中的规约实现的一些事情真的非常迷人。所以findif是我们通过规约实现的一整大家子算法。在并行算法中，通常像短路算法或者你可以提前放弃的算法，在我们的实现中这样做是没有意义的。好吧，放弃这个词有点用词不当。你已经找到了结果，所以你可以停止迭代。
Right, right. You can stop iterating, but in the case of something that you're going to GPU accelerate, it's actually more expensive to make an algorithm that's going to stop, that's going to be efficient, than an algorithm that's going to be fast. So making an algorithm that's going to stop as soon as it finds the result is going to potentially be slower than an algorithm that just exhaustively searches the entire input sequence. So we implement find if in terms of reduce, and then we implement find if not in terms of find if. And interestingly, we implement partition point in terms of find if not, and we implement mismatch in terms of find if not um uh so so essentially we implement
对，对。你可以停止迭代，但在你要进行GPU加速的情况下，制作一个会停止、会高效的算法，实际上比制作一个速度快的算法成本更高。因此，制作一个一找到结果就停止的算法，其速度可能比仅仅穷举搜索整个输入序列的算法还要慢。所以我们是用reduce来实现find if的，然后我们用find if来实现find if not。有趣的是，我们用find if not来实现partition point，我们用find if not来实现mismatch……所以基本上我们实现的是
mismatch and then equal uh in terms of reduce and mismatch is an interesting one because i know that's one of your that's one that's an algorithm that's also near and dear to your heart so maybe you can talk a little bit about mismatch well so we're we're getting close to when we got to wrap this up but definitely i'll say a little bit about mismatch but first partition point i recently so in the follow-up to the talk that bryce mentioned at the beginning algorithm intuition was a another talk with a very similar title but they're completely different talks better algorithm intuition i point out that there are five uh binary searches in uh the algorithm header most people are familiar with at least least three. I would say at least one, the one is being binary search. And then there's two other flavors, lower bound and upper bound.
mismatch，然后用reduce来实现equal。mismatch是一个很有意思的算法，我知道这是你非常喜欢的算法之一，所以也许你可以多聊聊mismatch。好吧，我们快要结束这次节目了，但我肯定会简单说一下mismatch。不过首先是partition point，我最近——在Bryce在开头提到的那场演讲的后续中，也就是《算法直觉》的另一场标题非常相似但内容完全不同的演讲《更好的算法直觉》中——我指出在algorithm头文件中有五个二分查找。大多数人都熟悉至少三个。我想至少有一个，那就是binary search（二分查找）。然后还有另外两种风味，lower bound（下界）和upper bound（上界）。
And then there's a fourth one called equal range, which is basically a combination of lower bound and upper bound. But there's a fifth one that very few people have heard of, or have heard of, but don't realize that it's a binary search. And that's partition point. And this has come up recently twice in like code reviews of people asking, I need like a binary search, but that looks at two elements at a time. So it takes a binary predicate and finds the place where the element on the left returns true and the element on the right returns false for like some unary predicate, which you can then sort of fold into a binary predicate. I recently, the reason I'm going on this little tangent here is I recently discovered that
然后还有第四个叫equal range，它基本上是lower bound和upper bound的组合。但还有一个极少有人听说过的第五个，或者说听说过但没意识到它是一个二分查找的算法，那就是partition point。这最近在代码审查中出现了两次，人们问：我需要一个二分查找，但它一次查看两个元素。所以它接受一个二元谓词，并找到左边的元素返回true而右边的元素返回false的地方，针对某种一元谓词，然后你可以把它折叠成一个二元谓词。我最近——我扯到这个题外话的原因是我最近发现
we actually have a section in the C++ ISO standard for binary algorithms, binary search algorithms, and partition point isn't in it. It's in the section next to partition because there's partition is partitioned and partition point. So even in our standard, we don't acknowledge that partition point is the fifth binary search algorithm. But anyways, yes, and mismatch, mismatch is the generic version of adjacent find and adjacent find is the generic version of is sorted until and is sorted until can be used to program or to code is sorted. So that was like a relationship that I found. And interestingly, in the same talk that I just mentioned, better algorithm intuition,
我们在C++ ISO标准中其实有一个专门针对二进制算法、二分查找算法的章节，而partition point却不在其中。它在partition旁边那一节，因为有partition、is_partitioned和partition point。所以即使在我们的标准中，我们也没有承认partition point是第五个二分查找算法。不管怎样，是的，还有mismatch。mismatch是adjacent find的泛型版本，而adjacent find是is sorted until的泛型版本，is sorted until可以用来编写is sorted。所以这就是我发现的一个关系。有趣的是，在我刚才提到的那场演讲《更好的算法直觉》中，
I thought that this was amazing. I'm not sure actually, Bryce, if you recall, we had, you know, non-alcoholic beverages and what is that bar called? Shannon's at the top of NVIDIA. And that was the time when I had made this discovery that adjacent find was implementable in terms of what I had then called the most, you know, the worst named or the most poorly named algorithm in the C++ algorithm header. And I was scared to tell anybody because I wanted to be the first person in a talk to say, oh my goodness, look at, what do you think? And so I did this game where I said, what is is sorted implementable in terms of? And you said is sorted until.
我觉得这太棒了。其实我不太确定，Bryce，你是否还记得，我们有无酒精饮料，那个酒吧叫什么来着？NVIDIA顶楼的Shannon's。正是在那个时候，我有了这个发现：adjacent find可以通过我当时所称的“C++算法头文件中名字起得最烂或最糟糕的算法”来实现。我当时很害怕告诉任何人，因为我想成为演讲中第一个说“天哪，你看，你觉得呢？”的人。所以我玩了个游戏，我说：is sorted可以用什么来实现？你说是is sorted until。
And then I asked what's is sorted until implementable in terms of. And then I think you got adjacent fine. Then I said, and there's one more. And you couldn't get it. But no one got it. And so then I told you stood mism fine. Then I said, and there's one more. And you couldn't get it. But no one got it. And so then I told you it was stood mismatch. And I was super excited. I asked Sean Parent this.
然后我问is sorted until可以用什么来实现。然后我想你想出了adjacent find。接着我说，还有一个。但你没猜出来。没有人猜出来。于是我告诉你那是std::mismatch。我当时超级兴奋。我问了Sean Parent这件事。
And when I asked him what is is sorted until implementable in terms of, he skipped over adjacent fine and went straight to stood mismatch. So in my talk, I call it the sean parent game because um everyone should aspire to be as knowledgeable about your algorithms as he is um because he he just knew it off the back of his hand so what one one of these episodes we will talk about you and your fanboy love for sean parent that's that's fine we can do that i mean that's an appropriate topic uh everyone should be a fan boy of sean parent um i mean he he single-handedly can like him and kate gregory basically uh he started sort of the the road to my public speaking um and then kate gregory
当我问他is sorted until可以用什么来实现时，他跳过了adjacent find，直接说出了std::mismatch。所以在我的演讲中，我把它叫做“Sean Parent游戏”，因为每个人都应该立志于像他一样对算法了如指掌，因为他简直不假思索就能答出来。所以，在以后的某期节目中，我们会聊聊你对Sean Parent的粉丝之情，这没问题，我们可以聊聊这个。我的意思是，这是一个合适的话题，每个人都应该成为Sean Parent的粉丝。我的意思是，他单枪匹马——就像他和Kate Gregory基本上一手开启了我的公开演讲之路，然后还有Kate Gregory——
i stole the title of my talk um from from her cpp cast episode i think it was 30 um but yeah like when i when i see sean's talks like they they are so inspiring um and they just make they make me want to like inspire i hope that like someday i can inspire people like the way that like sean inspired me um yeah his c++ seasoning talk his generic programming talk when he talks about how reading alexander stepanov's code was just like mind-blowing for him like that's that's just like so my favorite of his talks was i think his c++ now 2014 uh keynote where he talked about um he talked about um essentially porting uh porting some adobe app to run on the ipad and talked about um sort of the fundamentals of where you can get performance on modern processors and how you
我从她的CPP Cast节目（好像是第30期）里偷了我演讲的标题。但真的，每当我看到Sean的演讲时，它们都太鼓舞人心了，它们让我想要去激励他人。我希望有一天我也能像Sean激励我那样去激励别人。他的C++ Seasoning演讲、泛型编程演讲，当他谈到阅读Alexander Stepanov的代码对他是多么震撼时，那真的……我最喜欢他的演讲应该是他在C++ Now 2014的主旨演讲，当时他谈到了基本上把某个Adobe应用移植到iPad上运行，并谈到了你在现代处理器上如何获得性能的基础知识，以及你如何
have to turn to parallelism and how you have to turn to accelerators to get performance and uh as somebody who's in that field i just thought just thought it was just a super inspiring talk. And I mean, at the time, I was really in the HPC world. And Sean is not somebody who's an HPC programmer. And I was really awestruck with how many of the things that he was talking about. Like he was talking about getting performance on an iPad.
必须转向并行性，必须转向加速器来获得性能。作为该领域的一员，我只是觉得这是一个超级鼓舞人心的演讲。而且当时我真的深耕HPC（高性能计算）世界。Sean并不是一个HPC程序员。我对他在演讲中谈到的那么多内容感到无比震撼。比如他在谈论如何在iPad上获得性能。
An iPad is not an HPC platform. But the way in which he was talking about. Like he was talking about getting performance on an iPad. An iPad is not an HPC platform, but the way in which he was talking about it was just as applicable to how you get performance on the world's largest supercomputers. And I was just like, wow, this guy knows his stuff. Yep, Sean is an inspiration. Yeah. And maybe with that, maybe we should call it right there.
iPad不是一个HPC平台，但他谈论它的方式，对于你如何在世界上最大的超级计算机上获得性能同样适用。我当时就想，哇，这家伙真懂行。是的，Sean是一个激励人心的人。也许就凭这一点，我们今天就到此为止吧？
Yeah, I think that's it. The final line of our first episode is Sean is an inspiration. And, yeah, I think with that, we'll just say thanks to everyone that's listening. And anything else you want to say, Bryce? No, I'm good. If you have a favorite algorithm and you want to share it with us, go follow us on Twitter at ADSP The Podcast and let us know what's your favorite algorithm. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，我想就是这样。我们第一集的最后一句话是“Sean是一个激励人心的人”。是的，我想借此机会对所有收听的听众说声谢谢。还有什么想说的吗，Bryce？不，我很好。如果你有最喜欢的算法想与我们分享，请在Twitter上关注我们 @ADSPThePodcast 并告诉我们你最喜欢的算法是什么。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。